Which teammate's locker smells the worst?
I cannot say that.
Where are you from?
I'm from Caguas, Puerto Rico.
What is something you're bad at?
I can't play soccer.
My feet are not coordinated enough to play soccer.
And I can't sing.
I wish I could.
I'll be on tour right now if I could sing.
Alright.
What did you want to be when you were growing up?
I wanted to be a dentist.
That's it.
It was always either baseball or dentist.
How much do you think your signature is worth?
I hope, I hope at least 20 bucks.
What is your favorite hobby when you're not doing baseball?
I love sleeping.
No, no.
I like playing paintball.
Paintball?
Paintball, I love playing paintball.
What's your favorite meal that your mom cooks for you?
Lasagna.
I love lasagna.
My mom makes the best lasagna in town.
Wherever we go, she's the queen.
Who is the fastest player in your team?
The fastest player in my team?
I used to be the fastest, not anymore.
Yeah, I agree.
They came up, I'm not anymore.
What do you like about Cleveland?
The people.
I like the people in Cleveland.
People in Cleveland are nice like you.